mengukur superposisi kuantum itu seacak melempar koin tapi sejauh mana analogi
itu bisa kita bawa sebelum mulai runtuh kita akan cari tahu hari ini di Qiskit in the
classroom selamat datang di Qiskit in the classroom sebuah seri video di mana kita mengurai konsep fundamental yang mungkin kamu
temui dalam kursus terkait Quantum Computing setiap video disertai modul interaktif yang ditautkan di
deskripsi di bawah jadi pastikan kamu lihat itu hari ini kita bicara tentang salah satu prinsip inti di jantung
teori kuantum yaitu superposisi dalam pengalaman sehari-hari kita objek selalu memiliki fitur yang pasti lokasi ukuran
bentuk warna semuanya ditentukan dan pasti bahkan jika kita sebagai pengamat belum mengukurnya dalam
dunia kuantum ini belum tentu berlaku sebuah objek kuantum bisa berada dalam sesuatu yang disebut superposisi dari
beberapa state yang diizinkan secara klasik yang ketika diukur akan secara acak runtuh ke salah satu
state itu mengukur state superposisi itu seperti melempar koin tidak ada cara untuk mengetahui sebelumnya ke sisi mana ia akan
jatuh indeterminisme fundamental ini adalah aspek mekanika kuantum yang tidak nyaman yang bahkan Einstein pun kesulitan
dengannya dia dengan terkenal mengatakan Tuhan tidak bermain dadu tentang keacakan ini tapi seperti yang akan kita lihat Tuhan ternyata memang bermain dadu atau dalam
kasus kita Dia melempar koin tapi lebih dari itu koin-koin ini dibeban mengukur superposisi kuantum mungkin mirip dengan
melempar koin dalam beberapa hal tapi superposisi itu sendiri jauh lebih kaya dan lebih kompleks dari state
probabilistik klasik untuk melihat ini kita akan memikirkan bagaimana koin klasik bekerja dan membandingkannya dengan
koin kuantum kita yang akan kita jelajahi menggunakan Qiskit pada komputer kuantum IBM pertama koin klasik itu
cukup sederhana kamu lempar koin dan ia jatuh entah kepala ke atas atau kepala ke bawah dengan kemungkinan 50% untuk masing-masing secara teori kita bisa
menghitung sisi mana yang akan jatuh kalau kita tahu kondisi awal yang tepat dari koin dan persis berapa
banyak gaya dan torsi yang diterapkan selama lemparan tapi dalam praktiknya tidak ada cara untuk mengetahui sebelumnya sisi mana yang
akan jatuh itulah kenapa kita menggunakan lemparan koin sebagai contoh kanonik dari state probabilistik klasik di mana
hasilnya pada dasarnya acak kalau aku melempar koin ini seribu kali dan mencatat jumlah kepala ke atas
dan kepala ke bawah aku akan mendapatkan histogram yang terlihat seperti ini jadi kita punya hitungan di
sumbu Y dan bisa berupa kepala ke atas atau kepala ke bawah dan
histogramnya akan menunjukkan bahwa ada sekitar 500 hitungan dari masing-masing dengan beberapa
fluktuasi statistik kita bisa membuat state serupa menggunakan qubit pada komputer kuantum kita seperti lemparan koin sebuah
qubit juga bisa diukur dalam dua state yang mungkin nol dan satu jika kita menerapkan sesuatu yang disebut Hadamard gate ke
qubit itu akan menempatkannya dalam superposisi yang sama antara nol dan satu berikut adalah
visualisasi circuit itu yang kita sebut diagram circuit di sini kabel di atas adalah
qubit dan operasi yang diterapkan ke qubit ditampilkan sebagai kotak-kotak pada kabel Hadamard gate ditampilkan dengan kotak ini
berlabel H dan pengukuran ditampilkan dengan kotak abu-abu berlabel simbol pengukuran kecil ini mengirimkan
pengukuran ke bit klasik kabel dengan dua garis ini jadi karena qubit berada dalam superposisi yang sama antara 0 dan satu ketika
kita mengukurnya akan ada kemungkinan 50% kita mengukur nol dan 50% kita mengukur
satu kita mengekspresikan state superposisi kuantum ini sebagai s = 1 / akar
2 kali 0 + 1 / akar 2 kali 1 di mana kuadrat dari masing-masing
koefisien ini yang juga disebut amplitudo adalah probabilitas mengukur setiap state jadi efektivnya menerapkan Hadamard
gate adalah analogi melempar koin dan seperti kita melempar koin seribu kali untuk melihat
statistik koin jatuh kepala ke atas atau ke bawah kita bisa melakukan hal serupa di Qiskit dengan koin kuantum kita
kita akan menggunakan Qiskit primitive yang disebut sampler yang akan mengulang circuit beberapa kali untuk mengambil sampel statistik
dari state yang dihasilkan dengan seribu sampel dari circuit di atas kita punya sesuatu yang terlihat pada dasarnya identik
dengan histogram koin klasik dengan beberapa fluktuasi statistik jadi apakah itu dia superposisi kuantum
pada dasarnya sama dengan state probabilistik klasik yang mirip dengan melempar koin tidak juga ini akan menjadi
video yang cukup pendek kalau itu kasusnya untuk melihat perbedaan kunci pertama kita aku akan mencoba sesuatu yang sedikit berbeda dengan koin klasik saya daripada
hanya membiarkannya jatuh ke meja jatuh kepala ke atas atau ke bawah aku akan melempar koin dan menangkapnya
di udara di antara telapak tanganku sekarang koin tidak kepala ke atas atau ke bawah tapi sebaliknya entah kepala ke kiri
atau ke kanan jadi logika memberitahu kita bahwa ini juga harus memiliki probabilitas 50/50 untuk menjadi
kepala ke kiri atau kanan untuk mengukur kepala ke kiri atau kanan pada koin kuantum kita kita bisa melakukan apa yang kita lakukan dengan koin klasik
mengukur sepanjang sumbu yang berbeda pengukuran standar kita pada komputer kuantum adalah sepanjang sumbu vertikal
sama seperti pengukuran kepala ke atas atau ke bawah yang biasa dari koin klasik tapi kita juga bisa bertanya pada koin kuantum kita apakah itu
kepala ke kiri atau kanan kita menyebut dua state ini sepanjang sumbu-x plus atau minus
untuk ini kita menggunakan Qiskit primitive yang disebut estimator untuk memperumit sedikit daripada mengembalikan histogram seperti
yang dilakukan sampler estimator akan memberi kita nilai ekspektasi dari observable mana pun dari qubit untuk
memahami nilai ekspektasi ini katakanlah kamu mendapat satu dolar setiap kali koin jatuh kepala ke atas dan kehilangan satu dolar ketika ia
jatuh kepala ke bawah nilai ekspektasi adalah berapa banyak uang yang bisa kamu harapkan untuk diperoleh rata-rata dengan setiap lemparan koin karena
kamu sama-sama mungkin mendapatkan atau kehilangan satu dolar nilai ekspektasi akan menjadi nol penalaran yang sama bisa diterapkan
ke qubit ketika kita menemukan nilai ekspektasi dari x ketika kita menerapkan x ke state plus kita
mendapatkan nilai + satu dan ke state minus kita mendapatkan minus satu jadi kalau kita punya
distribusi 50/50 kita akan mendapatkan nilai ekspektasi nol tapi kita tidak kita mendapatkan nilai ekspektasi plus satu
artinya koin selalu diukur menjadi plus sepanjang sumbu-x itu akan seperti melempar
koin menangkapnya dan memastikan bahwa kepala akan selalu menghadap ke kanan ini karena
superposisi bukan hanya distribusi probabilitas ingat bagaimana kita mengekspresikan state kuantum
s sama dengan C 0 dikali state 0 plus C1
WEBVTT
dikali state 1 di mana masing-masing koefisien ini bersifat kompleks artinya mereka
memiliki bagian nyata dan imajiner jadi mereka memberi tahu kita tentang probabilitas tapi mereka juga menyembunyikan kuantitas lain yang disebut
fase beberapa koefisien C bisa ditulis seperti
ini di mana C sama dengan besaran kali fase ini di mana fi ini adalah
fasenya ini sedikit seperti fase gelombang atau lokasi puncak dan lembah gelombang kalau dua gelombang berada dalam fase
satu sama lain sehingga puncak dan lembah mereka sejajar maka mereka akan bergabung membentuk gelombang dua kali lebih
tinggi kita menyebut ini interferensi konstruktif kalau mereka berada di luar fase seperti
ini maka mereka mengalami interferensi destruktif saling membatalkan sepenuhnya untuk melihat bagaimana fase bisa menyebabkan
interferensi pada koin kuantum kita mari kita coba menerapkan Hadamard dua kali bukan hanya sekali sekarang secara klasik
ini tidak akan masuk akal kalau menerapkan Hadamard setara dengan melempar koin maka kamu tidak bisa melempar koin yang sudah melempar tapi mari kita lihat apa yang
terjadi secara mekanika kuantum jadi kita menerapkan Hadamard dua kali dan kita mengambil sampel state yang dihasilkan
luar biasa kita tidak lagi memiliki probabilitas 50/50 histogram yang dihasilkan menunjukkan bahwa di setiap kasus kita mengukur
qubit berada dalam state nol jadi Hadamard kedua telah mengembalikan qubit ke state nol dari mana kita memulainya
ini sedikit rumit untuk dilihat pada awalnya tapi ini berkat interferensi state kuantum tapi daripada
mengalami interferensi di ruang nyata seperti gelombang yang sebenarnya interferensinya terjadi dalam ruang informasi abstrak dari qubit
Hadamard kedua menyebabkan bagian nol dari superposisi mengalami interferensi konstruktif sementara bagian satu dari
superposisi mengalami interferensi destruktif dan menghilang mari kita jelajahi lebih jauh kita bisa mengubah fase menggunakan
sesuatu yang disebut phase gate jadi sekarang mari kita terapkan Hadamard untuk membuat superposisi terapkan phase shift
Pi radian dan kemudian terapkan Hadamard kedua sekarang koin kuantum kita sepertinya selalu keluar dalam state
satu phase shift pi menukar bagian-bagian dari state superposisi yang berada dalam fase dan di luar fase satu sama lain
jadi state akhirnya adalah satu bukan nol ini akan seperti melempar koin dan saat ia di udara bisa
entah bagaimana menerapkan operasi yang akan memastikan bahwa ia selalu jatuh kepala ke atas atau selalu kepala ke bawah tergantung pada
operasinya tidak mungkin dalam kasus klasik tapi tidak dalam kasus kuantum apa yang kita pelajari dari eksperimen ini adalah
bahwa kemampuan baru koin kuantum ini disebabkan oleh fasenya kualitas yang dimiliki superposisi kuantum tapi tidak dimiliki
distribusi probabilitas klasik jadi lemparan koin biasa sebenarnya bukan analogi yang bagus untuk superposisi
karena tidak mengatakan apa pun tentang fase ini aku pikir kita bisa melakukan lebih baik aku akan melakukan eksperimen lain
dengan koin kita aku punya koin yang duduk di atas meja kepala ke atas untuk membuatnya kepala ke bawah aku bisa membaliknya begini
ini adalah ekuivalen komputasi dari NOT gate katakanlah kita ingin membangun operasi yang jika diterapkan dua kali akan
ekuivalen dengan NOT gate ini kita bisa menyebut operasi ini akar kuadrat dari NOT jadi pikirkan apa yang kita secara fisik lakukan
ketika kita menerapkan NOT gate kita memutarnya 180° misalnya di sekitar sumbu-x jadi kalau kita memutar koin
hanya 90° di sekitar sumbu-x itu akan memberi kita akar kuadrat dari NOT jadi kita sudah menerapkan
akar kuadrat dari NOT kita dan koin hanya duduk di tepinya sekarang kita bisa bertanya apakah itu kepala ke atas atau kepala ke bawah nah
jelas bukan keduanya tapi kita bisa menambahkan langkah ke proses pengukuran untuk memaksanya menjadi kepala ke atas atau kepala ke bawah sekarang
koin akan jatuh ke sisi kepala ke atas atau kepala ke bawah dengan probabilitas yang sama lagi secara teori kita bisa memprediksi
ke mana ia akan jatuh tapi dalam praktiknya ini cukup sulit untuk diprediksi sehingga pada dasarnya acak kalau aku ingin
mengukur apakah itu kepala ke kiri atau kanan aku bisa menekannya ke arah itu dengan cara serupa dan itu sekali lagi akan memberi kita
probabilitas 50/50 antara kiri dan kanan tapi dalam dimensi ini kepala ke depan atau ke belakang
kepalanya sudah menghadap ke depan jadi 100% dari waktu kita akan mengukurnya kepala ke depan jadi sementara pengukuran x dan z
menghasilkan hasil acak pengukuran Y akan selalu menghasilkan hasil yang sama kalau kita mengingat kembali
eksperimen lemparan koin kuantum dari bagian sebelumnya ini mengingatkan bagaimana koin kuantum berperilaku setelah
menerapkan Hadamard qubit diukur menjadi nol atau 1 dengan probabilitas 50/50 dalam arah Z tapi
selalu state plus dan tidak pernah state minus sepanjang X ini menunjukkan bahwa mungkin koin yang berdiri diam di tepinya
adalah cara yang lebih baik untuk memvisualisasikan state superposisi dari qubit daripada koin yang melempar liar di udara
mari kita terapkan gate akar kuadrat dari NOT pada koin kuantum kita di Qiskit kita punya circuit sederhana ini
kemudian kita akan menggunakan estimator untuk memeriksa nilai ekspektasi dari tiga observable X Y dan Z yang semacam
seperti meruntuhkan koin kita sepanjang masing-masing dari tiga dimensi seperti yang baru aku tunjukkan jadi nilai ekspektasinya adalah 0
minus satu dan 0 untuk X Y dan Z masing-masing ini adalah hasil yang sama yang kita
dapatkan untuk rotasi akar kuadrat dari NOT yang diterapkan pada koin klasik kenyataannya ada analogi yang tepat antara
koin dan state qubit sekarang kita bisa memvisualisasikan state qubit sebagai vektor yang menunjuk ke arah kepala
pada koin tegak lurus terhadap permukaan koin jadi kepala ke atas atau state nol
pada koin kuantum setara dengan vektor yang menunjuk lurus ke atas kepala ke bawah atau satu menunjuk lurus ke bawah dan setiap
superposisi yang sama antara 0 dan satu menunjuk secara horizontal fase dari state kuantum menentukan arah horizontal yang tepat
ke mana ia menunjuk misalnya apakah ia menunjuk sepanjang sumbu-x atau sepanjang sumbu-Y atau di suatu tempat di
antara vektor ini dikenal sebagai vektor Bloch dan sepenuhnya dan secara unik menentukan state kuantum dari
qubit tunggal sekarang kita bisa membayangkan kembali setiap gate yang sudah kita lihat dalam video ini sebagai rotasi atau serangkaian rotasi pada
koin atau secara ekuivalen pada vektor Bloch NOT gate adalah rotasi
180° di sekitar sumbu-x ketika diterapkan ke state nol atau kepala ke atas ia terbalik ke
state bawah atau satu akar kuadrat dari NOT hanya 90° di sekitar sumbu-x yang sama dimulai
dari state kepala ke atas ini memutarnya ke kepala ke depan phase gate adalah rotasi fi di sekitar sumbu Z karena
kepala ke atas sejajar dengan sumbu Z ini tidak melakukan apa pun pada koin Hadamard gate sedikit lebih rumit kita
awalnya menyamakannya dengan melempar koin membuat koin berputar tak terkendali di udara tapi Hadamard sebenarnya adalah
WEBVTT
rotasi yang terkontrol dan deterministik dari koin seperti semua gate lainnya Hadamard dilakukan dengan memutar 90°
di sekitar sumbu Y lalu 180° di sekitar sumbu-x jadi diterapkan ke state kepala ke atas ia
berakhir menjadi kepala ke kanan jadi tidak ada yang acak tentang state superposisi kuantum atau salah satu
operasi standar yang kita lakukan pada qubit setiap operasi bersifat deterministik dan reversibel satu-satunya
saat keacakan muncul adalah ketika kita memutuskan untuk mengukur state kuantum apakah suatu state kuantum bahkan berada dalam
superposisi sebenarnya hanya ada dalam pandangan pengamat seperti yang mungkin sudah kamu temui kita bebas memilih
sistem koordinat kita X Y dan Z bisa menunjuk sepanjang tiga arah ortogonal mana pun jadi
kalau kita punya superposisi dari 0 dan satu dalam satu sistem koordinat kita bisa mendefinisikan sistem koordinat baru atau yang disebut
basis baru di mana state menunjuk murni dalam arah plus Z dan karenanya tidak berada dalam state superposisi
jadi ketika kita mengatakan qubit berada dalam superposisi kita juga harus mendefinisikan sistem koordinat atau
basis kamu mungkin meninggalkan modul ini dengan kesan bahwa kita baru saja menghilangkan semua misteri dari mekanika kuantum
bagaimanapun juga salah satu aspek yang katanya paling aneh yaitu state superposisi dari qubit sebenarnya hanya sesederhana
vektor tiga dimensi tapi ingat bahwa koin masih hanya sebuah analogi dan bahkan vektor Bloch pun
hanya alat visualisasi untuk menghitung probabilitas hasil pengukuran kita tidak bisa mengatakan apa yang sedang dilakukan state kuantum
sebenarnya sebelum diukur karena memeriksa itu memerlukan pengukuran kita akan membahas
konundrum tentang apa sifat sejati dari state kuantum dan bagaimana fenomena kuantum entanglement bisa membantu kita
menjelaskan ini dalam episode lain dari Qiskit in the classroom yang semuanya tentang pertidaksamaan Bell sementara itu meskipun jika kamu
ingin bermain dengan koin kuantum untuk belajar sendiri tentang state superposisi dari qubit dan cara mengontrol
mereka kunjungi modul koin kuantum yang tertaut di deskripsi terima kasih sudah menonton dan sampai jumpa lain kali